and they did everything they did last
year yeah went 11-5
won a playoff game with no off-season
program
no pre-season new head coach who became
coach of the year in kevin stefanski
that makes it even more amazing the
question is will they and
other teams have a full and meaningful
offseason program
this year we spent a lot of time talking
about the issue yesterday
the issue is still at full boil the nfl
unveiled its plan for the off-season
program
and its centerpiece is a four-week
window from may 24 to june 18
of 10 ota sessions practices
right practices not in pads right core
of the off-season program when offense
defense special teams for the year get
installed
and that three-day mandatory mini-cam
the union chris
continues to push back and yesterday we
didn't have a lot of the facts a lot of
the details about what the nfl was
proposing
they're going to test these guys every
day the mesa pcr
on-site test as reliable as the off-site
test you get an
answer in 30 minutes all the protocols
from last year
still apply the union still opposed
to the plan proposed by the nfl still
recommending
that teams specifically players
not show up for the voluntary portion of
the off-season program i still believe
it's going to collapse
i really do one key fact chris and this
is why i'm even more convinced it's
going to fall apart
the week before the veterans are
eligible
to show up for on-field practice that's
when the rookie mini camp will have yeah
right
mini camp draft picks undrafted
free agents who surely will be asked to
commit as we said yesterday
to showing up yeah before they're given
that contract right and
try out players you know they'll have 40
or 50 guys or more
in the building on the field before
the opportunity even arises for the
veterans to boycott
that's going to create some momentum
that's going to be very hard
to turn back around once you have all
the rookies there
all the undrafted free agents there
whoever happens to make the team
on a tryout basis you think they're not
going to show up the next week
yeah right start that's right hell no
they're going to be there
so i i still i understand what they're
trying to do
it ain't going to work it it's not going
to work and it's going to give the nfl
more power in the relationship when it
fails
and i don't want it to i don't want find
an off-ramp brandon mcmanus the broncos
nflpa rep was trying to use the off ramp
yesterday saying well now that we know
more about it yeah right i saw that
where where
yeah and then the nflp says oh it's
still not good enough so there went that
off-ramp they need to find another one
at some point well like your point like
about the veteran player after the draft
all that like spot on
like even before the draft you know as a
veteran player you know what
position your team is thinking about
drafting you hear the rumors you see
things oh i'm a middle linebacker
whoa everybody in the mock drafts got us
taking a middle linebacker
wait or you know everybody says that's
our biggest need on our football team
to that to your point mike those kind of
guys too
you know virtual
on virtual off-season drills
like what the hell is that like hey
coach look at me and my ipad
does my technique right when i'm out
here in my what my backyard
doing like shuffles like what what the
hell is that hey no i need a coach to
look at me
are my hips you know positioned the
right way am i stepping the right way am
i placement of my foot when i'm coming
out of a break
if i'm a receiver or db like all those
nuances are lost within
you know this whole thing and i think a
smart veteran player who understands
like where he's at in his career and
things like that
even before the draft they're gonna go
in they're gonna go wait i gotta worry
about me
i gotta worry about me and i gotta get
better for me because i don't know if
i'm going to be on this team next year
and whatever else
and i that's where i agree with you mike
i think it it does collapse that way
because i think you're going to have a
few guys that just love football and
want to get better and they're going to
go
to hell with the nfl pa and that's not
going to be a great look for them
another thing that the nfl recognizes is
that
these players will be working out
somewhere and a memo that was sent to
teams last night
in response to the nfl's reaction
to the nfl's virtual and on-field
combined off-season program the nfl
reminded all teams and i think this was
a clear message to the nflpa
if guys work out on their own and they
get injured on their own
it's a non-football injury and they
don't have to be paid
that is the shot across the bow that is
the point that we made
yesterday if if tom brady calls you up
and says we're not showing up for the
otas we're not going to the team
facility we're going to have solidarity
here we're going to
back our union brethren but i expect you
to be at the local high school
at 8 30 a.m sharp tomorrow because we're
getting the playbook installed on our
own
i'm saying sorry tom but unless you're
going to pay my salary if i tear an acl
on that crappy field
i'm not going there i'm going to the
team facility sorry
sorry but i got to take care of my
family and unless you're going to take
care of my family
if i tear an acl and they don't pay me
this year i'm going to go
take that injury risk in a spot where
i've got insurance
in the event that that injury occurred
no i mean it's a that's a real aspect i
mean
you're right it's warning shot across
the bow i mean that's what the nfl is
doing they're basically telling you like
listen
this is a year that you weren't then
they're going
you're not going to get away with it
they're they're letting you know right
now they're trying to like
set forth you know normalcy back again
with the nfl the off season the coaches
know how important it is
you know the owners and front office
people know how important it is not only
for them to evaluate their own teams and
figure where they're at
they they know ultimately it's best for
the players too the players can say all
they want
you know they're not right in this
argument of like hey we're going to take
the offseason off and do nothing
and first off now the fact that we know
that there's going to be testing
procedures and all that
there is no there's no excuse there's
zero excuse in the matter
at all so that's where you know i'll
again i'll disagree
with jc tretter you know when some of
the things he said the younger guys want
you know the off-season off mo just as
much as the older guy the
younger guys don't know what they want
they're just
oh wait you're you're you're asking a
bunch of 23 year olds that
hey you can collect checks and don't
have to work
in the off season yeah what do you think
they're going to say
well no i want to get back in there and
grind it out
like that's just that that mean they
don't know what's good for them
yes i know you so you said i know chris
is referring to comments from union
president and brown center jc treader
yesterday on the rich eisen show here on
peacock let's listen oh i jumped the gun
today and then
that's all right that's all right you
gave you gave everybody an appetizer
here's what he said we'll have the
dessert on the back end here's trevor
from rich eisen show yesterday
my job and our job as a union is to know
what our players want
and this is what our players want and we
surveyed our players and the vast
majority of our players
think the virtual off-season is the best
for this year
and that wasn't just the veteran saying
that just as many young guys just as
many guys with one year of experience
two years of experience three years of
experience
responded saying that they think the
virtual offseason is the best thing for
them
this year as the older guys did so
that's
a narrative that just doesn't have any
factor or proof to it it's just
used to try to divide
the the union but we know what we want
we
we as players talk and we as a union are
in charge of representing what all
players want
and that's what we're doing that
response was given
specifically to the question of what
does tretter have to say about guys like
bruce arians who say the veteran players
are just looking to
keep the younger cheaper players
down and that was the response from jc
tretter saying that they've surveyed the
players and the young players
first year second year third year guys
also don't want to do it now
this opens the door to a question i'm
going to ask
the nfl pa i want to see the survey
questions
i want to see exactly what the question
was i want to see how many guys
responded
my thought is number one the question
was loaded as you were alluding to
earlier hey would you like to would you
like to work
more and make less money check yes
or no right in the big box right yeah i
mean
surveys are easily manipulated also if
i'm a first year second year or third
year guy who knows i've got a job
and knows i'm gonna get paid
yeah i'm fine with no off season program
i'm not trying to make the team i know
i'm on the team
and even though it's less applicable to
them than the veteran players the
veteran players trying to save their
jobs
the younger players would just as soon
do what 21 22 23 year old guys do
exactly practicing right they'll
practice on their own terms they'll be
fine
i got a job right but if you survey
if you survey the guys who fall between
spots number 54
and 75 right now before let's say 54 to
65
and then you've got all the draft picks
and undrafted free agents on the back
end who aren't even in a position to
vote yet
those guys are all going to say we want
to be there we
need to be there my agent's telling me
to be there whether i want to be there
or not
i'm going to be there my spouse is
telling me and asking what do you hey
wait a minute don't you want a job
don't you want you know think about
that's the other angle i was thinking of
earlier
spouse significant other mother of your
child anybody that you're living with
who understands the connection between
showing up in april and may and having a
shot at being on the team in september
is going to be advising you in no
uncertain terms
as well a family member right get your
ass to work
that's right you got you got a chance to
get a paycheck this fall
right and if you don't go you got less
of a chance to get one yeah that's right
and you got the advantage of going there
and being in person and johnny you know
the guy you're competing with is at home
you know playing xbox
madden right now and you know he's not
there so go ahead take advantage of that
agreed or if you just ask an ex-player
like me or a player who's just retired
they're honestly going to sit there and
tell you that those young
those early years of your career are
important
the off season that's where the real
growth is made
you know like i don't sit here and think
like jc tretter's li i don't think this
was like a plan where he got together
with other veteran players and they were
like hey
how can we get together and screw the
young guys so we can last longer
no i i don't think it's like that i
think there is some
of course real caring for the players
and the situation like that
but you know yes you're asking young
young guys young men young kids i look
at myself back in those days i was a
young kid
i didn't know anything i didn't know
what was good for me you know
and yeah you give a lot of people in
that position
23 24 years old with a little money in
their pocket already
and physically have always been gifted
and be able to get things done for the
most part they're going gonna think i
don't need it no big deal
and that's not true they don't know
what's good for them i'm sorry i'm not
trying to say anybody's like
ignorant or anything like that i'm just
saying they're young
young professionals they haven't learned
the ropes yet that way
and it doesn't injustice and it did and
it did again
i know jc tretter made other comments
too it did the game injustice
the game wasn't as good last year you
know i i know fantasy was probably
awesome i get it
but for me for a guy that was pure x's
and o's and everything like that too
i definitely noticed a a notch down and
the quality
especially on the defensive side of the
ball a little what we talked about
yesterday no i'm not alone
coaches in the nfl tony dungy talked
about it during the year i mean it was a
real thing so there was a lot of issues
about not having an off season last year
i wonder if the union president was a
defensive player he'd feel as good about
the way that the play went last year one
of his arguments right
scoring was was up higher than ever yeah
because defensive play
was worse than ever worse i
look chris chris i
i don't think that anyone is
gathering in a smoky back room and
saying let's figure out how to screw the
young players right
i just think it's inherent to this
unionized workforce it goes without
saying i am older i am
far more expensive guy who just signed
an
undrafted free agent contract is
significantly younger
he's significantly healthier he can do
more things physically than i can
and he's a lot cheaper and the salary
cap this year
is 25 million dollars lower than where
it would have been but for the pandemic
and they're looking to save wherever
they can
if if i can avoid
letting that young kid take my job
and bump me to the status of former nfl
player
or cast me out into that that blender
of where am i going to find my next job
and which team is going to give me a try
out or a chance on the practice squad or
whatever
i'm i'm naturally inclined right
to support a situation where it's less
likely
that that someone who is younger and
cheaper and healthier is going to bump
me off of the roster so
i don't think it requires a conspiracy
or a meeting
or even conscious thought yeah it's
inherent to the way
right this union is that that's the
problem and i'm not saying there
shouldn't be a union for nfl players
but when jc trader says we represent the
interest of all players i say it's
impossible
it's impossible because there isn't one
cohesive
set of interests for veteran players the
interest is let's not have offseason
workouts so we have a chance to make the
team
for the young players the interest is
let's show up
so we have a chance to make the team he
said people are trying to divide the
union it's inherently divided
he's trying to pull together something
that can't be pulled together
that's the truth chris yeah i agreed
agreed
i mean yes you're going to have a number
of players who of course are going to be
or disagree with jc tretter's approach
and then
far greater than that is the number of
players who really don't know
any of the details of the cba or any of
this that's going on
and they're kind of just hey whatever my
player rep and the leaders on my team
tell me to do i'm gonna do
i don't really know what the hell is
going on so there's people that are
misinformed
and then of course there's people on
both sides of the fence when things like
this happen too
you know as unlike you brought up
yesterday aaron rodgers he didn't see
he didn't like the way things were going
he said the hell with this job i'm not
getting involved in it
500 members of the union didn't vote on
a 10
or it was an ultimately 11-year
collective bargaining agreement 500 guys
didn't cast a ballot
in in a union that had maybe 3 3 500
total eligible voters
500 didn't vote do you think they're
engaged in a survey about the off-season
program do you think they're going to do
anything
that anyone other than their agent tells
them to do
that's the thing that's lost in all this
the agents are going to decide whether
or not this boycott works and the agents
know
my duty to my client is to help my
client get and keep a job yeah i'm
telling my client
show up right for the off-season
workouts especially the younger guys
who otherwise would not make the final
53. yeah without those extra
opportunities
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports